welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber a little more than a
year after a former Microsoft design
executive was gunned down in a targeted
attack police say they have made a
second arrest the new husband of the
victim's ex-wife the fatal shooting
happened in Jacksonville Beach Florida
in February of 2022. Jared breydigan had
just dropped off his twins at their
mother's home and was headed back to his
own place with his two-year-old inside
the car when he came across a tire in
the road when he went out to move it
someone shot him and police say that
that someone was 62 year old Henry
Tennant when police arrested him this
past January he agreed to plead guilty
and testify against any other
accomplices now this week authorities
announced the involvement of Mario
Fernandez Saldana he is married to bride
against ex-wife according to an
affidavit tennan lived in a home that
was owned by Fernandez Saldana and
investigators found three checks that
Fernandez saldano wrote to tenen last
fall also phone records also show them
show the men had contact with each other
more than 60 times while police didn't
say Brad well they did say that bride
again and his we've had wife had a
bitter divorce and a tense relationship
afterward an exact motive has not been
released so let's break this down I'm
here with Terry Austin I'm here with
Brian buckmeyer Terry authorities didn't
say if there are any additional suspects
but they're continuing their
investigation what else could they be
investigating right now well if I'm
investigating this case I am definitely
looking at the victim's ex-wife because
she could be behind the entire scheme
now one of the things they have to do
obviously is look at any sort of digital
records that's how they connected tenant
and saldano and I think if they look
closely enough they could look for a
connection with her if she still is
angry
so Brian let me let me jump in here
because I think Tara we're having a
little bit of an audio issue so Brian
the arrest warrant for Fernando Saldana
heavily redacted but what would be in it
that would be the most damning for the
defense so Jesse There are three things
that I need to focus on here from the
defense these three checks the almost 60
messages those both prior to the murder
as well as after that and the fact that
the death penalty is on the table now
the relationship was one of landlord and
tenant if I can try to get the facts
that those text messages and those
checks may have been related to that
relationship we might be in the clear
but if they're what the prosecution is
suspecting that these are text messages
are an arrangement to murder a plan to
put this tire in the middle of the road
and and sneak out and understand his his
drop off and pick up time for his
children that's very damning and the
fact that the death penalty is on the
table is scary to me as a defense so we
have to figure out these checks text
messages and Communications around this
timing sometimes that paper trail tells
so much in these alleged murder for
higher plots well in other news for you
the jury in the xxxtentacion murder
trial down in Florida they took a day
off and right now their deliberation
time in the Jury Room sits at more than
26 hours the slow pace of deliberations
has been frustrating for the three
co-defendants the attorneys involved and
you know what our viewers as well the
jurors are deciding whether the three
men on trial robbed and killed rapper
xxxtentacion real name Jose enfroy on
Thursday the jury requested that they be
allowed to leave early and not come in
Friday because of some appointments the
judge agreed to that and he wasn't happy
when he saw a look of agitation on the
face of the lead prosecutor
jury oftentimes came in when they were
told to
at the start time and because of motions
and other arguments that came up
overnight
sitting back there for hours waiting for
us to start
so I think it's somewhat disingenuous
for the parties now to Grumble above
their
scheduling
determination of virtives is an
important matter that cannot and should
not be rushed it helps neither side
it will take the time that they need to
pay and
I don't have any difficulty with that
I get it we all want instant
gratification but that's not always the
way it goes so we spoke with a trial
consultant who specializes in Jury
consulting and trial strategy to get her
take on this very lengthy deliberation
it could be that they don't all see
things the same way
um you know that they don't remember
everything the same way so they want to
you know take another look at the text
messages or take another look at the
photos
um they just seem to be very thorough
and thorough juries I mean I think
that's really what we want we like to
get their verdicts we like to know what
they're thinking but
um sometimes they want to really take
their time and they juries always want
to get it right
but how that looks is not always the
same and uh you know they they may they
may just be really pouring over
everything and make sure that they feel
good about their decisions important
decision and juries do tend to take it
very seriously
and welcome back everybody a man died in
custody at a Virginia mental hospital
last week and 10 people are now facing
second degree murder charges officers
responded to a burglary report on March
3rd and identified 28 year old Ivo
otieno as a possible suspect police
forced otiano to be evaluated at a
hospital based on their impression of
him at the scene and at the hospital
otno reportedly became physically
assaultive towards the officers as he
was arrested and then he was taken to
jail but on March 6 just before 4 pm
officers took otiano to Central State
psychiatric hospital to be admitted and
just three and a half hours later police
had to investigate his death after being
told otieno again quote became combative
during the admissions process seven
employees from the Enrico County
Sheriff's Office turned themselves in on
Tuesday and three Hospital workers were
arrested while his body is currently
undergoing an autopsy prosecutors say
surveillance video shows otno being
smothered to death his family had a
chance to watch that video that hasn't
been released to the public as of yet
here's what they said in a press
conference on Thursday
my son was tortured to put it right
I saw the torture
there is no way
that Henrico County Sheriff deputies
were on him seven people seven officers
on one man my son was treated like a dog
worse than a dog
I saw it with my own eyes on the video
it started and it went on and it went on
until he took his last breath
Terry the obvious question is was this
an excessive use of force and what
constitutes excessive use of force in
Virginia well under Virginia law Jesse
excessive use of force is defined as
objectively unreasonable use considering
the totality of the circumstances and
what they want to look at is what is
going on what kind of crime might have
been committed they look at here in this
instance whether or not he was resisting
and if you look at the circumstances
here he was already in handcuffs and he
was being held down by seven people so I
think it's very easy to come to the
conclusion that this was unreasonable
use of force and that they certainly did
contribute to this man's death by all
being on top of him at the same time it
just reminds me of the George Floyd case
yeah so Brian these charges have been
filed on a criminal information what is
that and what would be next for the in
the case of these defendants so Jesse an
information is a written accusation of a
crime where there's a pen penalty like
jail time and it's written by a public
official under oath so it's simply a
prosecutor saying this is the
information that I know I am as an
officer of the Court taking an oath that
they're true and I'm signing off on them
and you're presenting them to the court
The Next Step around information is it
has to be especially if it's a felony an
indictable offense and so they're going
to present it to the Grand Jury the
grand jury will review the evidence
review the video review all of the
information probably after the autopsy
because they are going to want to know
what the actual cause and manner of the
death is and from there we are likely to
see an indictment and then the case will
progress towards Discovery and then
potentially a trial all right we'll
continue to monitor that one and in
another sad case the family of shanguela
Robinson is demanding diplomatic
intervention as the killer of the 25
year old remains at large this week the
White House addressed the case for the
very first time Robinson went on a group
trip to Mexico back in October and
within two days she would be pronounced
dead her friends blamed Robinson's death
on alcohol poisoning but an autopsy
showed that there was severe trauma to
her neck and spine a viral video
surfaced after Robinson's death
appearing to show her being severely
beaten in a hotel room Mexican
authorities are investigating her death
as femicide this is a form of
gender-based violence caused by one of
her friends on the trip now Robinson's
family with the help of civil rights
attorneys wrote a letter to President
Joe Biden and in that letter they
included statements from employees at
the Mexican resort that the group stayed
in naming Robinson's killer as de Janae
Jackson during a White House briefing on
Thursday press secretary Kareem
Jean-Pierre commented on her death
go out to miss Robinson's family
and friends it is devastating what
occurred and certainly
the tragedy is just devastating and
we've been following the news here but
because because there's an FBI
investigation underway there's very
little that we can say we gotta as you
know we are very careful about
um criminal investigations or any
investigations that are currently
happening through doj in this particular
case FBI this is something that we're
clearly following here and our hearts go
out to her family